thank you let me start by sharing with
you a personal memory maybe an anecdote
it's no mystery when I took office
exactly five years ago five years and a
couple of weeks ago I paid my first
visit outside of the European Union to
Israel and Palestine including visiting
Gaza and I said at that time that I
believe that a two-state solution could
be achieved during my mandate this was
the goal that I kept in my mind and in
my actions all of these years and at
some points I have to say this goal
seemed to be getting closer but we all
know what the situation looks like today
this doesn't mean that the perspective
is not there and it's not valid anymore
I think it is a matter of political will
and political conditions and I'll get
back to that but today clearly if I paid
the same visit probably I wouldn't say
that I believe that that solution could
be achieved in the coming months or
years the very idea of two states today
has come under attack as never never
before from many sides yet we should all
know that the two-state solution remains
I'm profoundly convinced of this the
best and the only realistic chance for
peace and also for security in the holy
places this is a principled and a
pragmatic position at the same time
nobody nobody has presented a credible
alternative to States so far many
evaluate against but nobody has
expressed any clearer view Durkin
substitutes that objectively objective
realistically and any plan that is not
firmly anchored in international law and
let me add also in the profound
aspirations and interests of the people
not only of Palestine and Israel but
also of the region would ultimately fail
our support of the two states is a
matter of international law it's a
matter of
justice and democracy but as I mentioned
it's also a matter of realism in these
years we have worked full time to avoid
the dissolution of the two states
perspective and the work continues to
date even in such difficult
circumstances let me say especially in
such difficult circumstances because
sometimes we have the impression as some
of our friends in the UN system in the
Arab world but also a little bit far
away in Africa in Asia that especially
in this moment where it's so difficult
to keep the perspective alive that the
voices of wisdom and realism need to be
heard and need to speak up this is why
we have actually as the objective was
fading away kept the position and the
work at full speed and with all our
strength
this explains our position on all recent
developments first on settlements we
have always believed that border changes
can only be decided through direct
negotiations between the parties based
on the pre-1967 borders Israeli
settlements in the occupied Palestinian
territory are illegal under
international law they constitute an
obstacle to peace and threaten to make a
two-state solution
impossible in addition settlement
activity in East Jerusalem
seriously jeopardizes the possibility of
Jerusalem serving as the future capital
of both states we have never shied away
from restate in this position including
just a week ago and with a united
European position I hear many times many
inviting us to speak with one voice in
difficult types in difficulties this has
remained and remains the strong united
European Union position our position is
clear and unchanged also regarding the
security of the State of Israel firing
rockets on Israel civilian population is
simply unacceptable and I'm grateful to
Egypt for the diplomatic efforts which
helped to stop
the recent escalation now we repeat once
again Israel has the right to secure it
Israelis have the rights to security but
we are also convinced that security will
only be sustainable and real if it is
built on peace and on a two-state
solution as you know in these years we
have also worked constantly to alleviate
the suffering of the people of Gaza
with the Gaza desalination plant we are
providing on crete and long-lasting
support which will benefit Ospital
schools enterprises and every citizen of
Gaza yet the crisis in Gaza is
inherently political in nature and
requires a political solution the
closure must end and crossings must be
fully opened at the same time it is also
clear that Gaza is part of the future
state of Palestine and that Palestinians
themselves must find unity beyond their
divisions we know that the current
political outlook is uncertain both in
Palestine and in Israel discussions
among Palestinian factions have not yet
led to a substantial reconciliation
President Abbas has announced his
intention to set a date for elections on
the Israeli side the political stalemate
continues and might lead to an
unprecedented situation with the third
election in just one year it is my firm
conviction that with courageous
leadership a return to negotiations is
possible I am still convinced today five
years after my first visit as a high
representative in Palestine and Israel
that that is the goal and that is
realistically achievable actually I'm
convinced that this is the only
achievable sustainable realistic
solution to this conflict
and let me say personally I'm also
deeply convinced that out of all the
crises and conflicts of the region of
the Middle East this is probably the
easiest to settle in concrete terms
provided provided and this is the most
difficult thing to achieve there is
political will among the parties and
among the international players to
accompany this process there won't be
peace without a strong political
commitment by both sides and by the
international community
the European Union sites we have always
been and we will continue to be I'm sure
about that ready to support to encourage
to accompany all efforts to build peace
and security and a negotiated two-state
solution for Israel and Palestine
Thank You Saipem Oh get in here son
[Applause]